Speaker 1: Let's go next to Alan
from South Africa. Alan, welcome.
Speaker 3: Hey, obligatory. Can you hear me?
Speaker 1: I can hear you fine.
Speaker 3: Great. So my question is,
what do you think? What issues do you
think Joe Biden can address and in what
ways to maybe save his presidency at this point?
Speaker 1: So student loan forgiveness would be a
big deal. See being seen as successfully winding
down Russia's invasion of Ukraine. Not that it's
his job to figure it out, but if he could credibly
negotiate an off ramp for Russia, I think that
that would help him. Cannabis decriminalization, I
think, would probably help him as well. You know,
we have to be realistic because we're now under
six months to these elections and what can be done
in that amount of time. I don't think there's any
way in hell that he gets immigration reform done.
I don't think he gets taxes done. I don't think
he gets health care. So I'm just thinking,
like, what could realistically happen? And I
think that some student loan forgiveness could
somewhat of a solution in Russia, Ukraine,
maybe. And if he was determined, you know,
maybe something on cannabis. But I don't I
don't he doesn't seem super interested in that.
Speaker 3: Yeah, I think I agree there.
And the other thing I wanted to ask was,
would you consider covering more international
news? I know you can't cover everything. It
would be impossible. But there's so much
going on in the world. Like, for example,
the I don't know if you cover this actually the
the election in Philippines. It's a lot of things.
I know your audience quite international. Yeah.
I would consider covering some some some topics
that are going on in the world. I mean, apart
from obviously the Ukrainian Russian conflict.
Speaker 1: So we did cover the Philippines
election actually. It was on the bonus show, you
know, the award winning world famous bonus show
that Alex Jones doesn't like. Right. We didn't
cover it on the on the broadcast show. We I'm
always willing to do international stories. It's
just they tend not to do well. They they get very
little interest, reaction, engagement or reviews.
And at a certain point, you know, we're
not just picking stuff based on views, but
if we do something and there just seems to be very
little interest, it does make me question whether
it's the right thing to be covering, you know?
Speaker 3: Right. Okay. Yeah, that makes sense.
Great. Well, thank you so much. Have a good day.
Speaker 1: Thank you very much. I appreciate it.